some new Batman news it's the talk of
the town all right so the word is Warner
Brothers plans on rebooting the Batman
franchise after The Dark Knight Rises a
couple things go through my mind one is
uh and then the other comes to mind
after I look at the clothes the quote
from mr. Warner Brothers that guy whose
name I can't remember but probably
should is that they have one more Batman
movie to do with Christopher Nolan and
then they have to reinvent Batman what
is the word reinvent it's different than
reboot could be anyway maybe I'm just
being the optimist but if you look at
the word reinvent it could mean that
they just pass on the Batman cowl to
someone else like Batman Beyond or
nightfall or since Christopher Nolan's
not going to direct the next Batman
after the Dark Knight Rises maybe they
mean that another director is gonna take
the helm and they have to reinvent him
because they're gonna take him a
different direction I mean technically
speaking from Batman Returns to Batman
Forever Batman Forever was taking it in
another direction plus Christopher Nolan
is staying on as producer for the next
Batman movie after the Dark Knight Rises
that would be like Peter Jackson
producing a reboot of Lord of the Rings
a reboot that would negate his telling
of the story because that would be
really stupid or maybe Batman will hang
up the cowl and come back as an old dude
like in the Dark Knight Returns then
they can cast a really old badass like
Chuck Norris or Clint Eastwood and take
him in another direction
Eastwood already has the voice get off
my keypad or it could mean that they're
gonna reboot Batman which would be the
dumbest [ __ ] ever making a shitty Batman
movie and then rebooting Batman well
then making a reboot of that reboot is
kind of like tearing down a trailer to
build a mansion then tearing down the
mansion in hopes that you're gonna make
something better the Christopher Nolan
Batman's are really good there's no
reason to reboot the whole thing the
Hulk I could understand even spider-man
after spider-man 3 I can kind of
understand but Batman at this point now
so I don't see the logic in that this
also comes as they announced that they
want to make a Justice League movie set
to be out in 2013 which is really ballsy
since they don't have a script of
director actors and they've tried to do
a Justice League movie before he failed
but now since the Avengers movies taken
off everyone's psyched for that they
want to make a JLA movie a couple things
Marvel has spent a few years spread
across a few different movies to set up
the Avengers movie which is why people
are looking forward to it the JLA movie
is isolated in stone little box no one
in Batman mentions Superman no one in
Superman mentions Batman I'm pretty sure
in the Green Lantern they're gonna
mention neither so they're gonna have to
set up the stories of everybody in that
one movie and it's gonna feel like what
it is a really rush
project made to compete with another
franchise so I am not sure about the JLA
movie so the news of a Justice League
movie in the news of a possible Batman
reboot after an already awesome reboot
exists your thoughts comment below let
me know and if you want to keep up on
the uselessly random [ __ ] that I do
follow me on Twitter the links below I'm
competing with Howard Stern I have the
silent competition in my head I want to
get past the amount of Twitter followers
that he has yeah I was like five hundred
seven thousand I have six hundred
something just six hundred something so
follow me and I'll do stupid [ __ ] like
tell you what breakfast cereal I eat I
don't even need cereal doesn't matter
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]